so I got something pretty crazy for you
guys there's this youtuber who
impersonated a twitch streamer in order
to harass other popular twitch streamers
then he got his community to jump on
board and follow suit and unsurprisingly
this isn't the first time that he's
pulled this kind of [ __ ]
[Music]
so the youtuber is Maximilian mas that's
too many words so I'm just gonna call
him max the guy he impersonated goes by
the name of Wiest now max originally got
famous from literally posting YouTube
videos of him trolling people in
overwatch you know I'd love to play this
game but someone won't let me are you on
your period
so due to blizzards no toxic [ __ ]
policy obviously max eventually got
permabanned whatnot but naturally he
moved over to fortnight which is the
[ __ ] Wild West of video games at the
moment so Max's channel was steadily
growing and then back in January he
posted this weird-ass main video called
oh yeah yeah it's literally a two-minute
video where he just says oh yeah yeah
over and over and over again oh yeah
yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah yeah oh yeah
yeah oh yeah
while it's really [ __ ] annoying it
also has 13 million views okay
around this same time max decided to
take over YouTube and this is where we
started to see shades of him attacking
other people because he asked his
community to change their profile photos
to his profile photo and then jump in
the comments section of other famous
youtubers and spam oh yeah yeah over and
over and over again max in his community
went after some of YouTube's biggest
names from juvie squad to Nikkei 30
dantdm to ksi
they have all called him out for the
[ __ ] antics that he's been pulling
and that's kind of the point
max has gotten famous off of being the
dude that other youtubers hate now since
then Maxis continued to upload fortnight
troll videos with titles like I told a
black guy only white people can say the
n-word and fortnight being misogynistic
to female players that he cues up with
and just generally being a dick for the
fun of it alright so this brings us to
last week when twitch streamer Wiest
posted a series of tweets explaining
that no it wasn't him talking [ __ ] to
other streamers it was actually max
impersonating him this is not me this is
max or one of his friends using my
profile picture and my name even the
yellow that I use in my discord server
you can see it's actually the same close
to the same yellow that I use to go to
these streamers and and tell his viewers
to say terrible things in their chat and
say that they're from me and it's not
and the crazy part is instead of denying
it or trying to give any explanation at
all max just straight-up admitted that
yeah he was impersonating Wiest
well hey you want to know why we do it
yeah cuz it's funny cuz we don't enjoy
yeah we try not yeah we're just never in
his life no big deal now in the midst of
all of this mess it was streamers like
blues dank and illinit II who were being
harassed by max impersonating weeks on
top of that when we said that this
nonsense was affecting his twitch
presence where he earns reportedly
ninety percent of his income max pulled
this [ __ ] she makes 90 percent of
income from twitch he should have told
us that yeah
now we know what to misreport oh yeah
yeah
now what's [ __ ] nuts is that this
isn't even the worst thing that max has
done to this dude
cuz back in June when we scroll friend's
father passed away unexpectedly max and
his community attacked her in the
GoFundMe account that she had set up to
raise money for the funeral and medical
expenses and of course this wouldn't be
a story if it didn't [ __ ] hit live
stream fails and other people started
chiming in with their own horror stories
of dealing with Max and his toxic
community now in the aftermath of Wiest
tweets which have garnered almost 19,000
likes on twitter as of this morning max
apparently deleted everything in the
discord server that served as ground
zero for this [ __ ] hate fest and we
know there's a time and a place for
envelope-pushing humor on the internet
but in personating other people and
attacking other streamers is that's
going too far
there's not much I can do other than
post this tweet so people know that this
guy is a piece of [ __ ] and I know I'm
probably giving him attention that he
doesn't deserve but at this point my my
job is on the line and I want to
continue doing this and you know my
hands are tied
this doesn't mean that he wins but it
does mean that he's getting the
attention he wanted and I guess in some
way that is probably good for him
because lord knows that no one wants to
watch [ __ ] fortnight on YouTube these
days anyway sorry I really am
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else hit up our instagram twitter and
facebook pages
[Music]